another day under a hot sun
but people here hope the temperatures
won't be as high as previous days
it's those in rural parts of central
India who are the most vulnerable a lack
of electricity and water infrastructure
means they have little respite from heat
waves
water is a big issue I feel extremely
hot my hands and legs are always aching
there is this issue of power Cuts
because of this heat there are power
Cuts all the time these are the problems
I've been facing
in some Villages there is no running
water
people rely on Wells for their supply
and those in several Villages complain
of water shortages
in others entire families including
children have to work
during the summer months bricks dry
faster but working in the summer carries
risks
the sun is too harsh we Face a lot of
difficulty our children fall sick all
the time sometimes we also fall sick but
what to do the only work we have
otherwise there's no other source of
employment
rum's wife has been sick for two days
with heat stroke you can't afford to
stop working
it's estimated that 49 of the Indian
Workforce work Outdoors the heat waves
are placing an unprecedented burden on
public health Agriculture and other
systems some believe India's government
is underestimating the impact of heat
waves induced by climate change most of
these heat action plans don't specify
who they'll talk to to improve their
plans and whether they'll reach out to
vulnerable groups uh in in cities and
Villages so most of the time these
consultation mechanisms are also
inadequate
works as a guide at this tiger Reserve
he can earn six dollars a day but
recently even that's been hard to come
by
work days dwindle because of heat not
too many tourists come during Summers
because of the harsh heat we mostly stay
home because there are fewer visitors we
only managed to get to work twice or
Thrice in a week
India has a climate vulnerability index
through which it assesses its
vulnerability to The Climate crisis and
works within that framework the U.N and
climate scientists are warning heat
waves will be more common and the Indian
government is likely to come under
growing pressure to update its policies
to protect the most vulnerable
Al Jazeera